what's most shocking about season two is
that it's
it's completely different it's also in
the house
it's also spooky but it's certainly if
season one was about
ghosts and trauma season two is about
love
and envy and loss
where is she
haunting of hill house was such a smash
success
and now here we are two years later with
the haunting of fly manor
a lot of familiar faces but a very
different storyline i'm so excited that
we get to talk about episode 8.
when you first read the episode what was
your initial reaction
oh my gosh so i at the time had a brand
new baby i just had a baby after
hill house and i didn't know if i was
going to be in bly like like i said
we've been waiting and i didn't know
and so one day mike invited me into the
writer's room and i sat down and leah
pitched the entire story of episode
eight she just told it to me right there
and
i don't mean to be as dramatic as i am
but i am so i cried
i thought it was just such a
heartbreaking story i have a sister who
is very close to me
i love her dearly and to feel so seen to
have
that love story the love story of of two
sisters be told
is something that i think many people
can relate to and don't see very often
so it seems like when you were in the
writers room they had the entire
like plan fully fleshed out yeah they
knew
they broke that whole season together
they knew everything
well what were the biggest questions
that you still had for your character
once you first learned her whole
backstory the thing i needed to know
and needed to work out was how much she
loved arthur
did she love arthur was she using arthur
what was her plan
what was the whole arthur back story of
it
i also kind of wanted to figure out what
happened to viola's mother
i wanted those things that aren't quite
answered because they're not
necessarily important to the story we're
telling in 208 but
are important to me as the actor
do you see her
i only see you let's talk about the body
snatching
because i feel like we need to like
establish some rules and i was wondering
if you could help me with this
absolutely so the phrase it's you it's
me it's us
allows a spirit to kind of merge with
your body yes um
but we got to see that that flora and
miles were eventually able to like kind
of take back
control of their mind and push uh
rebecca
and peter out yeah why do you think that
danny wasn't able to completely push
the lady in the lake out of her well i
think um
viola as a stubborn full-grown like
passionate woman has a bit more
spiritual weight
than the children also viola created
this game
so she can change the rules or move and
go
things because she knows the inner
workings like she's the watchmaker so
she can open it up and
move the gears around and so i think
viola was cutting
danny off at every turn and so at the
end of the series we see
that danny is now in the lake like so
many others before her
but that the lady in the lake never
returns what was your reaction when you
learned that we kind of had a bit of a
bittersweet happy ending i loved that i
thought that it was such a
a correct ending for viola because she
really is a monster let's not forget
even though she loves her daughter
completely and would have did done
anything to get her include
kill lots and lots of people but at the
end when she sees that she's come
between another true love story
i think she leaves i think she realizes
that she has to give it up
because she is hurting the very things
she was fighting for which is true love
i love that people are going to fall so
head over heels
for danny and jamie's relationship like
this
love story is so gorgeous when danny
had viola in her and she was able to
have all those extra years with
jamie do you really feel like that was
purely danny or was viola kind of
part of their relationship like what do
you think
i mean i'm down for a throuple but i'm
not sure that that was really there
i think viola is too long gone for that
she's not really experiencing human
emotions
and i wouldn't want to take away between
of the i wouldn't want to take away from
the true love of those two women
i love that you said that she's too far
gone for that we definitely saw that
physically with her
as we lost her face over the years which
was
so haunting but i'm curious
were you always the lady in the lake
when we saw her throughout the series
was there a body double like break that
down for me
i had a wonderful body devil it's a
stunt woman and performer named daniella
dibb
and because like i had said i have a i
had a young baby at home
i could not fly up to vancouver and
gallivant in the middle of the night as
much as i wanted to
i was not capable of doing that i was
breastfeeding so i guess i was
gallivanting in the middle of the night
just in my own house as opposed to blind
manor
um so daniella did a lot of that body
double work for me
and i did some of it once i got up there
to shoot episode 8 i was able
to kind of step in and do a bit of the
work but she took
the the lion's share of that hard time
she stepped in most of the mud
yeah very cold mud very cold
i can imagine and and for it to track
that far i'm like wow she was really
dredging through it really
trudging through it but when you did get
to act out those scenes
like i said it's so haunting with that
faceless effect was that done in post
was it a makeup effect like walk me
through that
there are two ways it's done one is
through post it's totally done
in special effects but the other is
there is a silicone mask
that has its eyes cut out and like a
little split for the nose
for the mouth and the two little holes
for the nose and so it starts that way
and then that helps effects do it
but it's very creepy and very heavy i
was gonna say what did that feel like
did you get claustrophobic at all
but you know not every job is great all
the time exactly
you gotta you gotta push through it i
was very curious when we saw that
viola found the the child in her bed
and then we realized that that was the
same child that was moving the figurines
in the dollhouse
was the child when they were moving the
figurines
dictating which way the lady in the
lakes of route would go or was he merely
like kind of letting
flora know where she was he's letting
flora know
so the doll faced boy because floor gave
him a face
and a story he then repaid that by
making sure she knew where all the
ghosts were
and that's how her and miles could save
danny
every time they did i've been like i
need a nighttime story i need some more
milk
they were able to keep i'm gonna banish
you to the closet yeah you're gonna get
locked in a closet now that
i oh so good victoria just nails that
it was so scary yeah oh my gosh i had
the pleasure of speaking with victoria
and she was saying that
the one thing that she was bummed about
this season is that she barely got to
spend time with you
i know she victoria and i go back to
like the very very very first days of
hill house you know i picked her up to
drive her to her screen test
because she was so brand new and she was
an elenation of a car
and she was just oh she's just sweetness
and light she's so
talented i'm so proud of her for all
that she's done i love the fact that you
are married to the brilliant mike
flanagan
yeah he also is the executive producer
on hill house and blind manor so i'm
curious to know
do you get spoilers during your pillow
talk how privy are you to the new
seasons and storylines
the only pillow talk i like is spoiler
pillow talk
there's so many wonderful things about
being married to mike but i would say
getting to hear his stories first is one
of them
so do you kind of get to have like dibs
on like i would love to play that
character like how does that work out
i don't do that anymore i think it's a
little bit
um i don't know inappropriate a lot of
people ask him for jobs and i
i'm just like he clearly knows i'm an
actress
he knows what i do and so i kind of just
wait and it always gets
it's fun because i know it's like
christmas i don't know what mike has
planned for me
and then when he decides he wants me to
do something i'm ready to be there
do you get to know like the full arc
right away or does he like to leave you
little bread crumbs
um he'll give me all the information he
has luckily because otherwise i would
just bug him until he gave it to me
and you've watched the whole season i
got that benefit
i got for the first time in my life i
got to watch a mike flanagan
story from beginning to end and only
know what i was going to be a part of i
was riveted i binged the whole thing
oh wait so you only knew your part well
i sort of knew the story but i didn't
want to read any of the other scripts
and i didn't want to know the little
day-to-day minutia of the story i just
wanted to know what i needed to know
so that i could have this exact
experience which is i get to
watch the season and you know i'm such a
super fan of mics to begin with it was
oh so exciting what a gift what was your
reaction when you realized the big twist
at the end
is that the narrator was actually
january the gardener
i love that first of all i'm a huge
carlubgena fan
and so the second i saw her on screen i
was like i know something's going on
here and it was really fun that and
finding out uh that mrs gross was a
ghost
those scenes in the kitchen where she's
just doing it over and over again
and raul is just kind of leading her
through it oh
i loved that you know i've got to ask
you
about what you possibly know about
season three
fingers crossed for the next haunting
you know it's very important to me to
stay married and so i
just can't reveal anything but there at
least is something to
reveal mike has a plan i'm sure
[Applause]
[Music]
how about this would you be open to
returning
without a job haunting season three yes
needs me i'll be there
i love that well okay so i have a bit of
like an investigative question
for you so as you mentioned you had a
little baby when you were filming blind
manor and you have a little girl and her
name is
theodora isabel irene flanagan yes now
obviously you played theo in hill house
yes your character's daughter is
isabelle
in blind manor yes could we expect to
see
some type of irene connection for season
three
oh you know that hasn't happened but i
will pitch it you know
that's a good one for sure yeah some
kind of a little gotta keep it in the
family
yeah absolutely yeah theo's not gonna
have enough identity issues to begin
with
he's like mom that's so weird you named
me after your own character
it was an amazing character i think
about theo
all the time i think about what she's
doing i thought that it was
such a cool use of supernatural powers
in such a real world
just in case you're wondering theo is
now a social worker in portland
okay i was in are she is she still
together
absolutely and they have a little
daughter
this is like this is what i think about
when i can't sleep i miss the o
and i think about her all the time and
when i get stuck in my own life i'm like
what would theo do
and the answer is always drink vodka but
after
vodka it is a better choice than what i
was gonna make and so i just like i have
this whole life for her that happens in
my head in portland
she's having a great time i feel like
theo would borrow your nail art because
now that she's living a
gloveless life she wants to show him off
there's this whole
thing backstory that i had that i would
joke with mike about during season one
which is that theo um spent years and
years and years and years and years
finding a manicurist someone who just
like is a nice person
who thinks happy thoughts and so she
kind of goes there the way like other
people would go to a bar and like she
just holds
her hands and she just thinks happy
thoughts and gets her nails done but
then it took her so long
and she kept walking out of nail salons
just storming out
wait i love that i love that you still
think about theo a lot would you ever
want to revisit her or do you feel like
she had just such a perfect
ending that you almost don't want to
disturb it he just doesn't want to come
back
i like she's just it was too much it was
too much
as a child it was too much as an adult
she wants her anonymity and i think it
would be
cruel of us to force theo to live her
life in the spotlight again
one day i'm keeping my fingers crossed
well lastly it is spooky season
how are you and your family going to be
celebrating halloween this year
well we will be doing a very responsible
socially distanced halloween in our
house
where um i have a nanny that works with
us because we're doing work right now
and me
and mike and we will have little
stations of trick-or-treating and the
kids will get to go
and get candy i love that oh that's
amazing
well kate thank you so much for letting
me pick your brain
on all these different aspects no great
questions thank you like very
thoughtful questions oh thank you so
much no i loved the season and i found
that
watching the season twice made me like
it even more because i was expecting it
to
scare me as much as hill house did and
it didn't so i was kind of confused and
then i just
realized that you pick up on so much
more the more you watch it
and i think that's what people forget
about season one everyone felt that way
about season one
they were like what is this new genre
that's like drama but sort of scary
and you had to get used to it and then
you have to go back and experience it
it's like a total new game i'm sorry
i told you the story wasn't exactly sure